hey guys thanks so much for coming to
watch this episode of middle ground we
actually have some behind-the-scenes
footage on our Instagram that you shot
yes I shot some behind-the-scenes stuff
so yeah a lot of people ask us how like
sets go how they're directed and all
that if you want to check it out yeah
check out how Bonnie directed all these
middle grounds on Instagram and the
handle is right here okay yeah anyways
enjoy the episode in the meanwhile
thanks guys bye
do you have any idea how much the future
of my life changed because of your
decision in this moment you like altered
the course of my life
I lost my older sister to a heroin
overdose in 2013 and then two of my
other siblings also struggle with
addiction I was an addict for about ten
years but now I work with so many people
that are coming out of addiction in
order to help those on either end those
that are struggling with family members
that have addictions or addicts
themselves I am a mom of three children
who went to private school and I was a
heavily addicted woman on top of it I am
an alcoholic recovering alcoholic I have
been sober for over a year now a lot of
people think as a choice and it's
something that we just don't want to
stop doing and however it's a lot deeper
than that I'm a recovering alcoholic and
drug addict you know you never know what
you put somebody through you only know
what you feel so my dad is an alcoholic
it'll be good to hear a perspective from
the other side and how it kind of
affects them and how they feel about it
[Music]
hey guys I'm Morgan I live in Los
Angeles
I run a creative agency name is Derek I
live in Los Angeles I'm look at the
Orange County rescue mission as a
program director my name is Chris Gianna
I'm 22 and I'm a college student hi I'm
Jessica I'm 27 and I worked as a banker
hi I'm opera I'm not gonna give my age I
live in LA and I produce a film festival
so if I can get my attics to the left
and my loved ones to the right
addiction is selfish
I do think addiction is selfish I don't
think that it's by choice selfish but I
think you don't want people to really
see everything that you're kind of going
through or what your situation is and so
it's a very isolating disease and
therefore you feel like you're all by
yourself and you can only rely on
yourself
I don't know that addiction is selfish
but I know that as an addict I was very
selfish I thought of myself and the
drugs are the alcohol
first and foremost and I would you know
push aside or step over whoever was in
my way to get them I guess I find it
there's a danger to just labeling it
like addiction is selfish I think it's
dangerous to do that if you step back
and like you kind of have to separate it
because there's there's people who start
with prescription and it just you know
the doctors knew is dangerous and they
did it anyway kind of thing and I don't
think it's fair to label that person
who's now addicted to pain meds that is
not selfish that's like they kind of got
screwed over if that makes sense
I feel resentment towards the other side
just me there's been so many instances
of my dad you know going on his
week-long benders and since I got out of
high school it seems like it's it gets
worse every single time will always
he'll will have to get in the car and
hide from him or you know we'll have to
run up the street and call the cops on
him and just every time it seems like it
gets worse I just have a lot of built-up
anger and resentment towards my dad it
doesn't mean I don't love him any less
or I don't feel any different about him
it's just if you don't talk to me two
years ago with you and the only reason I
like change my perspective it's just
like a loss or and it just kind of I
went and like educated myself about it
and like learned all this stuff I'm not
going to judge anyone for feeling
resentment but I personally can't
anymore
coming from an addict and then being on
the level inside I can see and
understand that so the resentment is no
longer there's more of a pity and a
compassion and a heart to help them
because I know the struggle that they're
going through the resentment I hold it
isn't even for myself it's for my mom
because the way that he treats my mom
was drunk is like a completely different
story from the way he still treats me
bad but my mom is like a different story
and he's just very very angry and scary
towards her so the resentment I hold his
for the way that he treats my mom
cutting ties with a loved one with
addiction is okay
there's only like so much that somebody
I think can do we do everything we can
to help somebody right like in a
situation like this like send them to
rehab and I've had to do it we're like
kids will call me and they keep not keep
going out they keep doing sup they keep
lying and they're incapable of being
honest I think it comes to a point where
it hurts both of those people more to
not draw a line and be like look I'm
here if you want it but I can't keep
being a part of the [ __ ] in my addiction
long ago the turning point in my life
was when my sister had to walk away from
me when she was no longer offering me
help that was a turning point for me
because I recognized okay that was it
for me I had no one else
nowhere else to go no one no one else to
that will provide for me so that began
my upward climb if you will I remember
when my parents saw me get arrested my
brother told me that my mom went home
and she was laid on the floor my mom is
not an emotional person at all and she
just laid on the floor crying and so
that to me is saying one I have a
problem and I'm hurting the people
around me you know it's draining and it
affects them so much so yeah I
definitely think that cutting ties is
necessary to save yourself
addicts must hit rock bottom in order to
truly get better
March 16th 1999 was the time where that
was a rock bottom for me you know where
I was facing 19 years and I couldn't do
19 years so that was my rock bottom and
I had to cry out to God and ask like
Lord I need something different and if
you get me out of this I'll do whatever
you tell me to do and yeah I still had
to do time but my life changed from that
point forward because with my dad so
many times you know every time he goes
on his bender and you know whatever
happens me and my mom are like okay this
has to be it like if he can't like
obviously he'll come out of this like
he'll go back to AAA like every time we
think it's like his rock bottom and then
it's not so I'm like what is it actually
gonna take for him to you know think
about what he's doing and go back to it
I don't think you must hit rock bottom
to want to recover I know many people
who have hit rock bottom but that still
did not make them want to be sober and
for me the first time I had a DUI you
know that was that could be considered
my rock bottom but I wasn't out of ideas
but then the second time was more like
okay it just clicked something in me but
this time I was like I cannot continue
to live like this what are you think in
a sense that is kind of a rock we're in
your heart you can't do it anymore like
that is your you know stop in the face
like change it you're right everybody
has a different bottom but the concept
of a rock bottom I think is like you're
homeless
you know you're in the hospital
you're in you're 5150 like you lose
everything for me I was I had been in
treatment I had been in sober living but
I still made it you know it's still got
worse so what made you come to that
place where you decided okay I want
something different I wanted to live and
I wanted
get in my life you know that I think one
of the worst things that we can do is
continue to enable anybody if we love
somebody enough we will do whatever is
necessary know what afford them to to
get well and what I mean by that is if
we have to take things away if we have
to call the cops on them
to me that's does love well my question
with that is how you're talking about
you know it's necessary sometimes it's
necessary to get you know that out of it
it's like well how do you know if you
know you're doing the right thing so
it's like you don't let them come back
in the house or stuff like that it's
like well how do you know that's just
not gonna make their situation worse and
well yeah it will but it's like it will
make it worse
if they're dealing with like you know
mental health issues you know and they
it's just so bad for them that they
think you know the only way is you know
I'm not your responsible I know but it's
like saying the word a cake my dad out
and that's what what happened I would
never forgive myself for that you know
what I mean so it's like hard finding
like is this gonna make it better
or is it gonna make it worse cuz it
could go either way you know put your
decision now is not making anything
better what is it the present is not
better you know because you can't want
it more than he can want it for himself
regardless of whether you keep them in
will kick him out I don't think the
other side understands my experience
me working at the mission I know that
I'll it's a lot of people that have
Natalia why don't they just stop you
know I talk with a lot of parents of
people that are that are coming through
why don't they just quit they they're
hurting us or they're destroying the
family and they just won't stop and
that's just because they don't
understand the addiction they don't
understand that if that person could
quit or stop they would I've never felt
felt comfortable a day in my life like
ever
until I like was started to drink and do
drugs right I will I look at people and
they like they're just down the street
and they're like happy and they're like
doing [ __ ] and they're super normal and
I that's all like I ever wanted and I
could never get that ever got that until
I found like drugs how long that works
against you so it's like a constant
challenge every day full of like guilt
and shame and feeling uncomfortable when
I was younger I thought it was just that
my sisters didn't care about me and now
I think it's just that they had no idea
whatsoever what they were actually
putting me through especially when I was
very very young it changed my whole
family structure like her kids had to
come live with us and like as a five six
year old you know that's really
confusing so my family went from six to
ten overnight and we had to move across
the country and like all this stuff and
it's like do you have any idea how much
the future of my life changed because of
your decision in this moment you like
altered the course of my life and I
think a lot of people especially ones
with loved ones who are addicted are
trying really hard to see the other side
and I feel like sometimes people just
dismiss us you are as much in the
addiction as the addict you know because
you're in the sphere you in their
lifestyle is trying to constantly save
them I definitely do want to emphasize
that as much as I need help that my
family
it does need just as much help as I do
that's the part that's the part I feel
like you guys don't understand is you
guys kill us
not you but I'm sorry sorry I don't know
how so crazy you know it's addiction
it's just like it rips apart our life
and our family and everything and a lot
of times it works out you know people go
to rehab and it's all over whatever but
then there's the times where it's not
you know and the the weird part is like
okay
I'll put up with all the crap just bring
her back to life you know so I would
like to think that my dad understands me
and how I feel but at the same time I I
don't and I feel like this is true for a
lot of people on the other side it's
like you don't want to tell the person
that's going through it how it makes you
feel inside because you you don't you I
know that my dad already feels very very
low of himself so it's like I want to
tell him like you know this has caused
me a lot of you know emotional trauma
and anxiety throughout my life and I'd
like to think that he he understands me
but I know that I don't I don't tell him
how I feel like how it truly makes me
feel because I don't want to like I
don't want to hurt him more I don't want
him to you know feel really down and he
also deals with depression so I don't
want you know him to think oh I've
caused all this trauma to my daughter
like and you know do something I was
saying who've done a proper setting and
that probably that could be a
a wake-up call for him for him to hear
it from you of how is making him feel
yeah sometimes we're not aware it's
taken me a while to become more and more
aware of the damage that I did to my
children and I want them to tell me
recovery is possible recovery not only
is it possible it but it does make your
life so much better in the lives of
people around the lives of people around
you absolutely so in all actuality being
sober is like the greatest thing that
has ever happened it really is the great
I like I remember the first time I ever
[ __ ] laughed for real like I remember
the first time I like you know all that
[ __ ] like that just numbs for years and
years and years and all this stuff comes
back and you have a personality again
and you have a life again and you have
like relationships again and you have
all these things that like make life
worth living I mean I think I I believe
it's definitely possible and I hope you
know it is for my dad sometime in the
near future know before he you know gets
liver disease too or you know before
anything really bad happens as long as
there's breath there's hope yes yes you
know as long as this breathing is an
opportunity for you know recovery for if
you know a newness of life you know so
we just have to hold on to that
[Laughter]
[Music]